In this video, we are bringing you the first
official stills for the HBO’s upcoming Game
of Thrones prequel series House of the Dragon
which is about a Targaryen civil war known
as the Dance of the Dragons that tore Westeros
apart over 100 years before the original series.
Although production on House of the Dragon
is still very much in progress, audience is
getting a gift with official images of the
series’ main characters.
Here are some close-up shots of its main characters.
First up, we have the Sea Snake himself, actor
Steve Toussaint as Lord CorlysVelaryon with
silver dreadlocks.
This series is about a Targaryen civil war
that breaks out when King Viserys dies and
his children Rhaenyra and Aegon start a war
for the Iron Throne.
Both claimants to the Iron Throne have allies
and the most prominent on Rhaenyra’s side
is Corlys Velaryon, the head of an ancient
Valyrian house with a powerful navy.
Velaryons had for centuries remained the oldest
and closest allies of the Targaryens
and in this war, they chose to fight for Rhaenyra.
During the Conquest, it was Velaryon ships
that carried Aegon’s soldiers across Blackwater
Bay, and later formed the greater part of
the royal fleet.
The most famous and strongest Velaryion to
ever live is also one of the main characters
in the upcoming House of the Dragon show - CorlysVelaryon,
known as the Sea Snake.
He is a fabled Lord of the Tides during Targaryen
civil war, Master of Driftmark, and head of
House Velaryon.
House Velaryon, much like House Targaryen,
is of Valyrian descent, and its members often
have Valyrian features, such as silver hair,
purple eyes, but their skin is different because,
unlike Targaryens, they have married outside
their own family.
The Sea Snake is the husband of Princess Rhaenys
Targaryen, the Queen-Who-Never-Was, King Viserys'
cousin who especially loves Rhaenyra.
During the Dance of the Dragons, Corlys becomes
Hand to Queen Rhaenyra Targaryen who is his
niece and daughter in law as she marries his
son.
Sea Snake's life before the Dance of the Dragons
was just as exciting.
As matter of fact, he is getting his own Game
of Thrones Prequel show named „9 Voyages“.
Corlys is also a good friend of Rhaenyra’s
uncle-soon-to become- husband Prince Daemon.
Lord Corlys and his fleets fought alongside
Prince Daemon Targaryen during the War for
the Stepstones.
When Daemon declared himself the King of the
Stepstones and the Narrow Sea, Corlys placed
the crown on the new king's head.
Lord Corlys Velaryon sits on the black council
during the civil war known as the Dance of
the Dragons; he is the greatest lord to pledge
his strength to the cause of Queen Rhaenyra
Targaryen, who was opposed by her half-brother,
King Aegon II Targaryen.
More than half of Rhaenyra's army is made
up of men sworn to House Velaryon.
Corlys's fleet also gives the blacks superiority
at sea.
When Lord Bartimos Celtigar pressured the
princess to fly from Dragonstone to King’s
Landing at once and reduce the city to ash
and bone with her dragon, Corlys demanded
to know how that would serve them, telling
him "we want to rule the city, not burn it
to the ground", which tells you much and more
about his character.
Later in the story Corlys even saves most
of the great families of Westeros by sending
envoys to the Lannisters, Baratheons and Hightowers,
who had been Aegon II's main supporters, suing
for peace, preventing the Wolf of Winterfell,
Cregan Stark from marching on them as he wanted
to continue the war until all Rhaenyra's enemies
were destroyed.
Corlys is going to be one of your favorite
characters in House of the Dragon.
From Queen Rhaenyra's allies we go to her
enemies, Queen Alicent and her father Ser
Otto Hightower.
Rhaenyra is the chosen heir of her father
King Viserys, and totally expects to be queen
when he dies.
But as all good plans, this one fails as well
because she has a rival in the form of her
dad’s second wife Alicent Hightower and
her father Otto Hightower, the Hand of the
King.
Instead of Rhaenyra, they prefer that Alicent’s
first son by the king, Aegon Targaryen, take
the Iron Throne when King Viserys passes.
Alicent is of course wearing a green dress,
the color of her house and of her factions
that support her son Aegon while her father
Otto is wearing the Hand of the king pin as
at this time King Viserys is still alive and
he is his hand, although he held that same
position before King Viserys and will wear
it after him.
Alicent Hightower is a member of House Hightower
who becomes the second wife to King Viserys
I Targaryen and therefore a Queen of the Targaryen
dynasty.
She is the daughter of Ser Otto Hightower,
who had been Hand of the King to Jaehaerys
I, Viserys I, and later his grandson Aegon
II.
She is the mother of King Aegon II, Queen
Helaena, Prince Aemond, and Prince Daeron.
Alicent Hightower is in many ways the true
leader of Aegon II's faction during the Dance
of the Dragons.
Alicent's father Otto Hightower had been Hand
of the King in the last few years of the long
reign of King Jaehaerys I Targaryen.
In 101 AC Otto brought the young Alicent to
the royal court, where she cared for the aging
king.
Jaehaerys eventually died in 103 AC, while
Alicent was reading to him and was succeeded
by his grandson Viserys I.
Alicent stayed at court, as her father continued
to occupy the position as Hand under Jaehaerys's
grandson and successor, King Viserys I Targaryen.
Already early in the reign of Viserys, Ser
Otto and Prince Daemon Targaryen were at odds
with each other, and the court fool Mushroom
has suggested that the quarrel between the
two men began when Daemon deflowered Alicent.
The truths of these tales have never been
uncovered.
Viserys I's first queen, Aemma Arryn, only
produced one living child before her death
- a daughter, Rhaenyra.
In the years that followed, Alicent caught
the eye of King Viserys I Targaryen, and Viserys
choose Alicent as his second wife.
They married in 106 AC, despite the whispers
of people who believed that the Hand had risen
above himself.
Some doubted Alicent's virtue, as rumors began
circling that she had given her maidenhead
to Prince Daemon, and had later even slept
with King Viserys while Queen Aemma was still
alive.
The notorious Mushroom suggested that Alicent
had been intimate with the late Jaehaerys
as well.
Nonetheless, Alicent was wed to Viserys.
At first young Rhaenyra and Alicent got along
well, but a rift grew between them as soon
as Alicent produced her own children for Viserys
I, and clearly wanted them to succeed to the
throne instead of her.
Alicent bore Viserys I four children: Aegon
II, Aemond One-Eye, Daeron the Daring, and
Helaena (who became the sister-wife of Aegon
II).
Over the years of Viserys I's reign, despite
his best efforts, a bitter rivalry grew between
Alicent and Rhaenyra at court, as well as
between their rival factions of supporters.
In 111 AC, a great tourney was held at King's
Landing on the fifth anniversary of the king’s
marriage to Queen Alicent.
At the opening feast, Alicent wore a green
gown, whilst Princess Rhaenyra dressed in
Targaryen red and black.
Soon afterward, their respective followers
started dressing in similar colors and styles
to display their political allegiance: Rhaenyra's
faction (the "Princess's followers") wore
black clothing, and Alicent's faction ("the
Queen's followers") wore green clothing .
Ultimately this inspired the nicknames for
the two factions: "the Blacks and the Greens".
The Blacks (Rhaenyra's supporters) included
the Starks, Tullys, Arryns, Tarlys, and Velaryons
(among others), while the Greens (Alicent's
supporters) included the Hightowersand the
Lannisters, among others.
The Baratheons started out as Blacks but switched
to the Greens when the civil war began, while
the Tyrells may have been Greens at first
but during the civil war itself declared themselves
neutral.
Viserys I publicly and repeatedly made the
great lords of the realm swear oaths that
Rhaenyra would succeed him on the Iron Throne,
as the first Ruling Queen.
But when he dies, his wife Alicent and his
Hand, Ser Otto will be the first to support
Aegon II who is their own kin and not only
support but stage a coup.
Last but not least we have this close-up shot
of Rhaenyra and Daemon Targaryen themselves,
the two key figures of this series.
Daemon is a younger brother of King Viserys
I Targaryen, while Rhaenyra is his daughter.
That makes them uncle and niece, who will
eventually also become husband and wife as
well because this is the Game of Thrones universe
and they are the true Targaryens after all.
Let me know in the comments down below if
you like the dragon scales on Daemon’s arms
and Rhaenyra’s dress.
Rhaenyra Targaryen,
King Viserys’ chosen heir, a dragon rider
who grew up expecting to become the first
ruling Queen of Westeros.
Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen, cheered as the
Realm's Delight when she was young and later
called the Half-Year Queen, was the first-born
child of King Viserys I Targaryen.
Rhaenyra was King Viserys I's only living
child by his first wife, Queen Aemma of House
Arryn.
At the age of eight, she was made her father's
heir and grew up expecting to become the first
ruling Queen of Westeros.
Rhaenyra was a dragonrider whose mount was
Syrax.
Rhaenyra had her family's Valyrian looks,
wearing her silver-gold hair in a long braid
in the manner of Queen Visenya Targaryen.
Beautiful as a child, Rhaenyra was later declared
by her uncle, later husband and the man who
is standing beside her in these pictures,
Prince Daemon Targaryen, to be the most beautiful
maiden in all the Seven Kingdoms.
Daemon Targaryen is also a key figure from
this time period and is George R.R. Martin's
favorite Targaryen.
Daemon was the most controversial man of his
lifetime, an audacious rogue prince and adventure
who seemed made of good and evil in equal
measure.
There was never a man so loved and so reviled,
and at the same time, as he was.
During the Dance of the Dragons, as the husband
of his niece Rhaenyra, he supported his wife's
claim, and he was considered by many the most
dangerous man in Westeros.
At the time of her father's death, Rhaenyra
was on Dragonstone awaiting the birth of her
child.
The greens in King's Landing ensured that
the news of the Viserys's death did not reach
her until her own supporters in the Red Keep
were dead or imprisoned and Aegon II's coronation
had already occurred.
This began a devastating civil war that tore
apart the Seven Kingdoms, known as The Dance
of the Dragons, as it was the only war in
which both sides had dragonriders.
There you have it guys, first official stills
for the upcoming Game of Thrones prequel series,
House of the Dragon that will air in 2022.
Stay tuned for more.
I hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you did please give it a big thumbs up and
I hope to see you in the next one.
Peace!